I don't know what we would have done if
we live in a state that wasn't that
supportive I don't know how I would've
been able to go back to work
how do we do that without exploitive
it's embarrassing that we live in this
beautiful wonderful country that doesn't
support working on the social safety
nets create peace of mind
I've seen other places where folks have
not had those kind of opportunities and
have to figure out and improvise in some
possible way
my husband and I were kind of shopping
around for places to settling I don't
know if I would have had my kid without
those resources I think we should all be
asking more of our government to keep
young people and the economy going and
all these things that you want in the
future really starts up a space level
with families